Here on the show we love
to shine a light on people,
who are working hard to help other people.
And today we have got this incredible story
of three cancer survivors.
And Gail's friend and CBS news colleague,
David Begnaud went out and filed this Drew-Gooder report.
(upbeat music begins)
(upbeat music fading)
Hi, I'm Kerry.
Hi, I'm Shelly.
Hi, I'm Katy.
[Kerry, Shelly, And Katy] And we're the cancer cartel.
I was diagnosed
with stage four non-Hodgkin's lymphoma.
I was diagnosed with breast cancer.
I battled breast cancer, thyroid cancer
and I've had an ongoing battle with skin cancer.
Kerry and I have been friends for about,
I would say five years now.
And me and Shelly are sisters.
Katy and I were talking about
how lucky we are to have made it
through our cancer journeys that we were meant
for more and the cancer cartel was formed.
We accept luxury donated items
or dollars on our website.
We sell it and a hundred percent of the proceeds go directly
into the hands of people fighting cancer.
We're going to send you a check in the mail today.
[Donation Recipient] Oh my gosh! Thank you so much!
[Donation Recipient 2] Oh my God! You guys are awesome,
Thank you so much!
[Donation Recipient 3] I'm really grateful, I really am.
I feel like I'm doing what I'm meant
to do with people.
I meant to do it with
and that there's nothing that can stop us on this journey.
(upbeat music)
Hey, Drew, it's David Begnaud
with CBS news.
I am on a very special assignment here
in Seattle to surprise Kerry, Katy and Shelly.
(door knocking)
Hello!
(group greeting)
Drew wanted me to surprise you guys
with this.
This is amazing! Are you kidding?
(group cheering)
You guys, you know what?
We never get anything for ourselves.
I'm going to start crying.
No, we don't.
"Drew Gooder"
That's awesome.
Oh my gosh!
Thank you Drew!
Thank you so much!
Oh my gosh! We're blown away
I don't really, I don't even know.
I have no words.
Coming here to surprise you guys
on behalf of Drew.
Incredible
was so exciting for me.
Like this is personal because my mother had breast cancer.
[Kerry, Shelly, And Katy] Oh!
And so I got really emotional
watching what you all are doing
for other people to pay it forward.
We all have stories, but we shouldn't be here.
And it was meant to be that we were supposed to be
on this path together.
I always had the back of my mind.
I want to do something to give back, but I just
didn't know what that thing was until these two.
How does it feel to be recognized?
It feels..
[Kerry And Shelly] Surreal.
People have been so amazing coming
on board and support.
I mean, y'all are the Drew Gooders
that make the world a special place.
Thank you so much!
(crowd clapping)
[Drew} Joining us now, CBS
this morning lead national correspondent, David Begnaud!
(crowd cheering)
I really wanna compliment you because
sometimes when you see these pieces
you feel like it's all wrapped up
in a bow and it just makes you feel really good.
This is not only a feel-good story
but it's very incentivizing.
I want to do more with these women.
And I hope that other people feel that too, watching it.
I think your journalistic style is just perfection
because it's not like great.
That's all happening and taken care of.
I can move on with my life.
It makes me go.
I want to get involved.
Well, first of all, thank you
for allowing me to spread some joy on your behalf.
And I have to tell you Drew those women between the three
of them have had six different cancers almost right.
Six. So the gratitude they feel
for just being alive was palpable
and they were tickled pink that you thought enough
about what they're doing to recognize them on your show.
They were over the moon.
It's not enough.
I want to do more.
You know, I've seen many different interviews
with different people
but there's something about when David does the interview.
People open up to him in a way that they don't others.
He really does have a special gift.
So I'm not surprised you do you recognize that?
I absolutely did.
And out of curiosity, for all of us budding, you know
lovers of journalism and the art of conversation
Yeah
how do you get all of this goodness out of people?
I'll tell you what it is for me.
Short soulful questions,
this lady but there's nobody like her.
Right? I adore her, but what I try
and do is I go in and just be myself.
And what I do Drew,
is a lot of people are expecting big questions.
They prep all night.
They're like, he's gonna ask me the following.
And I go in and I go, but why did you
the moment you walked in
or why didn't you say, and it's the simple
short soulful that lead people to sort of go,
well you want to know my heart.
And when you can give me a piece of your heart
that's where the audience is going to come back.
All right, David, thank you,
David and Gail catch Gail on CBS this morning
and check out the new Oprah daily.
I love that it has the word daily on there.
We do too,
and watch Oprah and Gail live tonight
on zoom and go to our website
for a special Oprah insider offered that
by the way when I found out what it was,
my jaw dropped, check it out.
(upbeat music fading)